hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game from round eight of the
croatian grand chester being played in
zagreb it's vishwanathan anand versus
evan shahrich and
in the previous round uh even uh drew
his game against mamiyarov when the
ananda drew his game against the duda
and now
they uh face off in a very interesting
line of the sicilian defense
so hope you guys enjoy it uh let's check
it out and interestingly
we mentioned in the previous video that
even has a positive score against magnus
carlsen as he drew against him once and
won a game against him once
he also has a positive score against
anand in the 2018 world rapid
championship that was played
in saint petersburg russia uh charity
defeated anand and now anand gets chance
to
retaliate also in a rap game so let's
see how how it went anand has the white
pieces and he opens with e4
even of course always replies with c5
and when i say always i mean most of the
times we have knight to f3
e6 d4 and captures captures we have
knight to f6
knight to c3 and now knight to c6 the
four knights variation
and now a3 all right trends uh
transferring to the taimano variation we
have bishop to e7
and now knight captures on c6 we have b
captures now black will have very nice
support to execute d5 in the future
so white immediately jumps in with e5 so
attacking the knight
knight to d5 and now queen to g4 and now
putting pressure on black's g7 pawn
even has to decide how to deal with this
and the castling would be a bit
premature because then bishop h6 and you
run into trouble
so you basically decide between king to
f8 and the g6 both are
very much played even decides to go for
g6 and now
there are a couple of games where or not
couple there's one game where queen to
g3 was played
also knights the e4 is a known move
going after these dark squares but here
uh instead of all that anand plays
bishop to d2 and it is now already as of
multan that we have a completely new
game
so uh let's see how even deals with this
he first started by bringing the rook
over to the semi-open b
file putting pressure on that b2 pawn
and anand
continues developing just bishop to d3
saying that okay if you want to grab
this pawn you are more than welcome to
do it uh even of course not interested
in the pawn he just plays queen to c7
uh you can always grab the pawn but now
you're attacking this pawn as well
and anand grabs the knight on d5 as one
should in this line so knight captures
on the e5 and now you don't have time to
capture the pawn with
check because then the knight just goes
back and well you're down a pc
if you capture the b2 pawn it's still no
compensation white can just castle and
it's
not not a problem so instead after
knight captures on the e5 uh you have to
decide whether to capture with the c
pawn or with the e
pawn uh uh character decides to capture
with the e pawn
uh even though it seems a bit more
principle to capture with the c pawn but
the bishop nicely guards the c2 pawn it
doesn't seem like you'll be doing
anything on the c file so here he
captures on d5
and later on you might have some support
for pushing your c
pawn uh and here we have castles anand
just
leaves uh his e pawn and b pawn under
attack
because if you try and defend this uh
instead of
instead of castling let's say play
bishop to c3 you try and defend both of
these pawns
then c5 and now we see the point behind
the capturing
the the way even did because now d4 is
coming and you will again expose both of
the weaknesses for example cap
castles d4 and now the bishop has to
retreat from the defense of this pawn
also this pawn is under attack so
not really doing anything for white so
anand just castles and
now uh well now it's it would be too
dangerous to grab the e5 pawn if even
grabs this then rook just comes to e1
and that's it if queen to d6 we just
play bishop to f4 and that's it we win
the rook
this is uh there's simply too much um
dark square issues for black here black
will get completely destroyed here so
here
after another castle uh shot is just
castled and both players are doing very
well on time they have some 20 minutes
on the clock each
uh and here we have queen to d4 now
anand
has the opportunity to to go for some
very cool
lines with sound like bishop to h6 here
and it's a very tricky move problem is
after the rook moves for example rook to
e8 you can bring this rook
for example here to defend the pawn and
black still can't capture this pawn
uh because if he does for example black
captures you have this e6 move and white
wins uh because now well
obviously we're gonna bust open black's
king's side and if black decides to
capture this queen d4
threatens checkmate and also if you
defend checkmate you lose the rook on v2
so bishop to h6 a very interesting move
anand decides to play queen to d4
instead he defends both of his pawns
like this
so even now gets a chance to continue
development so he has to develop the
light square bishop bishop to b7
and now b4 so ana no longer has to worry
about his weaknesses
uh now it's time to continue development
but now he also makes it a little bit
easier for even to uh well
free his uh both of his bishops so here
we have c5 now
b captures bishop captures and now queen
to f4 and now the situation on the clock
is on it has some 15 minutes whereas
even has
maybe 18 minutes on the clock uh and his
bishop pair is very very strong
as you can see here both players have
the bishop pair but it's
um it will be very hard to activate both
of the bishops if you ever push d4 then
you block this bishop so
and it's very unlikely that you can just
you know make this pawn disappear
it's not like anand will just play c4 at
some point and allow you to free both of
your bishops like this
uh but okay we rook after e8 honing in
on this
weak e5 pawn and now bishop to b4 a very
tricky move by anand
and there's uh well there's uh
often a time in chest where uh the way
to play is just to make your opponent
decide on what's going to happen you
don't want to be the one that breaks the
tension so here
uh you can't really go after the e5 pawn
because then the bishop hangs and that's
going to be a problem so you have to
play something but what is it
you could do something like a rook to e6
and then bring this rook over to e8 but
even does uh a very interesting thing
and it's uh
it's actually the strongest move
recommended by the engine so for this
move
uh we're gonna award even the nikhil
kamath head as
here he played a5 so here uh he
basically he forces on it to
decide what to do with this bishop and
you can't really move this bishop
if you move it then everything just
becomes weak so you have to capture on
c5
bishop captures on c5 we have queen
captures and now
okay we can get rid of the nickel hammer
head now uh now rook 8 to b1
and here he's offering even this pawn
and while grabbing this spawn is not a
mistake in itself
uh maybe it's a bit too ambitious for a
rapid game for example captures on a3
and now you might run into some trouble
uh rugby three attacks the queen then
this rook is coming to b1
could be it could be very problematic
black can still play this you have to
play
queen to f8 so now the both the queen
and the rook guard this rook and now
of course rook to b1 makes no sense but
then white plays rook to a1
uh the game continues black is up upon
but it's a very
very uh you know weird position so even
avoids such lines
he goes queen to c7 now keeps his double
attack here
uh but now queen to d4 saying that uh
okay there's really no point in
capturing this uh if you if you capture
with the rook then i just play queen to
a7 and that's it you don't have a
you don't really have a way out here
whatever you play bishop to a6 is coming
and then you of course you will not be
able to capture the queen hangs and
there's going to be a triple attack on
the bishop
and if you capture with the queen
instead of the rook for example you go
for something like this then we can just
trade
captures captures and now rook b2 the
other rook is coming to b1
and the white is winning this there's no
defense if rookie 7 rook b1 and then you
can even play this to help out with the
defense but this bishop to a6 always
wins the game for white
so you have to uh you know uh decide how
the
situation will unfold here on the queen
side bishop to c6 is what even chooses
and now he no longer has to worry about
any weaknesses here on the b
file now the rooks are up for trade so
here we have
f4 on and now finally defends his e5
pawn
and now d6 you have to challenge this a
very very strong pawn
we have rook captures on b8 onan trades
off a pair of rooks
not root captures but rather queen
captures you have to keep the pressure
here on the e5 square rook the e1
uh bringing another defender and here
even traits we have captures characters
and now
uh at some point uh white might be
interested in pushing some like
a e6 to weaken uh white black's king
side also maybe h4h5 will be an idea
so for the moment just rook to e6
keeping an eye on that pawn not allowing
it to move anywhere
and the queen and the rook are now stuck
guarding this spawn and now there
isn't really all that much white can do
there is one move uh however
and it's a very tricky move because if
you play it you also make uh
uh black's light square bishop come
alive but i'm not afraid of anything he
just plays c4
and now he's of course threatening c
captures on d5 and the problem is if
even captures on c4 then bishop captures
attacks the rook and once the rook moves
e6 will just be extremely strong for
white you do not want to capture this
and allow
whites to you know take control of both
of these diagonals and if you place them
like f5 then you're stuck with this pass
pawn for the rest of the game
it's very unlikely that black will be
able to survive this
uh so instead after c4 we have queen to
a8
now even saying okay after this captured
i'm just gonna pick up the g2 pawn and
this will be good
for me so anand plays rookie 2 and then
now rook
back to e8 uh and both players now have
some six minutes on the clock and
what do you do here well on first first
place h3 create some breeding room for
the king
and now uh you could just try and waste
moves with some like queen to d8 and see
what happens but then anand might play
c5 then he gets a past c
pawn then also maybe ideas like a4
bishop to b5 can be played
so maybe a bit too much to allow so uh
here
even just captures on c4 we have bishop
characters
and now uh not waiting for e6 even just
plays
rook to d8 attacks the queen and now
preparing rook to d1
with check and it could be very nice the
bishop and queen attacking this way the
rule coming to the back rank
uh good things might happen so queen to
b6 now comes
rook to d1 with check king to h2 as
anand played h3 he made some room for
the king
and now bishop to d5 not allowing
this e6 move so now the bishop is under
attack here on
the traits we have captures captures in
the now e6
uh asking what do you want to do here
and even just captures we have captures
captures
and we get this position that
interestingly is um
is a complete draw but it's very hard to
realize that because it seems like the
white king is very safe and the black
king is wide open it seems like you're
very close to just you know getting
checkmated
but it doesn't work because here there
is one move that
uh a black and plate and that really
just immediately takes care of
everything
and it's uh well it's a it's a very nice
move so uh here
we have king to f7 now attacking this
rook the rook is attacked twice you
don't really have
uh anywhere to go to deliver a check you
could go some like rook to f6 check of
course but then just king e7 and
there's no way to continue the rook will
always be attacked by the king
and you will have to move it at some
point uh and that will allow black to
deliver this check and trade off the
the queens so on and of course not
interested in
just giving a check he moves the rook
back rook to e2 but now
queen to d6 check and now the queens get
off the board so queen captures rook
captures and now
rook to e5 going after this pawn we have
a4
sorry a4 by black uh now keeping the
pawn nicely defended here and
now rook to e4 again attacking it and
forcing ivan's rook to this passive a6
square to defend
his spawn so rook the b4 and now king
the e6 but
uh as both of them are very well aware
of this this is of course a dead draw
and it is only a matter of maybe maybe
trying to make the other guy make a
mistake and it's it is possible of
course anand is much better on time he
has some four minutes on the clock even
has a minute and 30 something on the
clock
so you know anything could happen but
king to f5 we have king f3
h5 now by even uh and king to g3 we have
rook to a5
but now king the h4 uh we have king to
f6 king to g3 king g5 and now king the
h2
king to f5 and here a few more moves
were played king g3 king g5 king h2 king
the f5 and after king to g3
it was in this position anu48 that anand
and chattish
agreed to a draw as there is nothing
more uh to be done here for
for either sides to push for for any
advantage so
really a wild game it seems like there
was um
there were maybe some better chances for
white and black both
but as this is a rapid game it would be
it would be uh you know
a bit too much to try and explore such
lines with so little time on the clock
uh but other than that this was
basically a a perfect game
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i think all the games from
round eight
ended in a draw and after uh eight
rounds it's still yanny punishing the
lead uh by a full point but since you
get two points for a win in the rapid
it's basically he's basically leading
for uh
by by you know by half a point you know
uh
one draw uh and followed by uh uh anand
here shotish and
mvl so we'll see what happens in the
final round can anyone catch up to
nipple or
will he be the leader going into the
blitz section of the croatian grand
chester
in zagreb uh so a very nice game hope
you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank kevin keith robert
arthur and jim
al boyd and happy birthday joan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day